hey lebron there's that nba added to it
it's so impossible to replicate
the physicality of an nba game except
for playing nba games just wonder how
you were able to
keep yourself physically at this point
to where frank said he was
you know pretty impressed with how you
looked and wondered how you felt in that
sense
um yeah i mean i haven't played in the
game in six weeks
and uh you know no contact no 505 i've
been doing a bunch of individual
workouts and and
um you know a lot of running trying to
keep my you know my heart rate going
my conditioning going and you know for
my first game in six weeks i felt okay
as far as my win i felt pretty good as
far as my ankle my ankle was a little
tight at times obviously just
you know just doing different movements
different things that i haven't done
obviously in the game situation in six
weeks so i think you know as the games
go on
that will continue to improve but um i
came out uh
unscathed and uh and and um you know
pretty good so
it's a good start frank talked about for
the team obviously a frustrating loss
just wonder what you saw that you think
is the most that you guys most have to
focus on
as you build up towards the playoffs
here at these final line games
i mean obviously it's on both sides of
the floor um i think
obviously our turnovers you know
hindered us a lot in the fourth quarter
um but also you know we gave up some
really good
looks for them in the fourth quarter and
uh we had a ten point lead at one point
we let that
dwindle down and we gotta do a better
job of that
it seems like so long ago when you guys
were 21-6
and it looked like a defending uh
championship run was you know like in
the cards everything moving in the right
direction
now where you got to stand with working
in the two new pieces
working you and ad back what
what is it going to take to kind of get
that that same type of feeling that same
type of confidence
the same type of rhythm to be when the
games tip off of the playoffs to be in
that same type of
place uh well minutes on the floor helps
you know the more minutes that we get on
the floor with our full unit now that we
have
will only help us um you know and wins
as well but we can learn a lot in our
losses so
um you know we got to continue to get
better um you know we are working in
like you said two new pieces
and drumming and uh you know and ben and
we're also working in
you know two new pieces that that was
already here and myself and a.d
you know so uh to the fourth to the
fourth so you know every uh
every opportunity like you said you know
film sessions and uh shoot-arounds and
you know it's not much practice time
obviously but the games we got to get
better from that
well
lebron frank said before the game that
he really feels like for his own
personal comfort level this is not
really enough time to do all the things
you guys need to do
before the playoffs in terms of
reintegrating and all that
um how much do you think you guys can
accomplish in these final nine games and
what do you think is just gonna
end up on ignition forward because of
how much time he's left yeah i mean it's
just
it sounds so weird bill what you're just
saying it's only nine games left it's
just been a
um it's been a hell of a season
obviously and uh you know everything
just felt so rushed
you know and uh you know uh you know
it's a game every other day
um or it's a game you know back to back
so you know
you can have as many four five games in
a week you know so
um you know it's been uh it's it's been
a
long super quick season so um
you know how much can we make out of
these nine games i'm not sure i know as
far as our chemistry we continue to
build that we continue
to build the log log minutes out on the
floor um you know continue to build some
things
obviously but um you know we can't it's
a difference just a different season you
know for not only for us but for
for a lot of teams you know and uh you
know but we look forward to the
challenge i mean um
you know it is what it is this is the
season and we got to make the most of it
hey lebron a little surprising to see
you the red sox out of nowhere
um two questions for you if you would
one the lakers have lost
four or five before tonight did that
give you urgency to come back and two um
you know when you hit your first bucket
the and one
in the first quarter um was that a
little bit of a relief from you testing
that
relief for you testing that eh uh well i
mean it's been urgency for me to get
back ever since i got injured
um so that's just who i am um you know
if you guys could have seen the the the
longing of minutes and hours
per day that i was doing as far as
rehabbing treatment um
it was uh a lot more than then i slept
um so i've been
that's over the last six weeks that's
all i've been doing is having an urgency
to get back and play
um i knew i would you know getting back
to 100
it's impossible i don't think i'll ever
get back 200 of my career
um but you know i felt comfortable where
i knew i could get on the floor and help
my team win
um two um you know that play i was able
to push off off my right ankle
um you know going left and and and you
know the ankle that was hurt
and be able to you know get a good step
on a really good defender and then
finish at the rim so
um you know that was a good step you
know for me uh mentally
thank you obviously this is the longest
absence of your career
somebody who loves the game loves being
out on the court so much
how challenging was that for you
mentally and is there any silver lining
there just in terms of this having given
you
sort of a reset of sorts um it was
horrible honestly
for me i i was more stressful
than i've ever been um you know
the first uh i would say the first you
know couple weeks was pretty good
because uh you know i wasn't allowed to
travel much or not or i didn't travel
much um
you know as the injury and you know the
swelling was what's happening with my
ankle
so i kind of stayed at home and um you
know didn't go on a couple road trips
with our team i was able to stay home be
with my family so
that was very rewarding but as far as
like watching the games and not being
able to play and
you know sitting on the bench and um you
know knowing that you couldn't make it
really of
you can't make much of a difference you
know it's very stressful so
but i'm happy i'm i'm playing now so a
little stress relief
mark medina hello lebron welcome back
um i know last year the season restarts
obviously some different players on that
team
different circumstances but to what
extent do you think you and some of the
other
players can draw from that experience
just telling
you guys how to deal with a long stop
that you play and
trying to get the ministry going before
the playoffs yeah i mean every season is
his own challenge and
obviously you know the experience of
last year is totally different from
what's going on this year
um you know but we can hang our hats on
knowing how we can perform in the
postseason we have a lot of guys that
return from our postseason team even
though we have some big guys that you
know that
now that are in other places now um so
but
um we have a lot of experience um you
know in the postseason on how to make a
run how to handle adversity and uh
we know we can always hang our hat on
that well the results and wins
uh that's for us you know the game is
played in between the four lines and not
on experience or on paper and things of
that nature
got to go out and do it too but you can
always go back and use some of those for
you know for some sometimes where you
just feel like okay can i do this or can
i not
last one uh brown welcome back
just wondering when you are sitting out
injured like that
how do you mentally sort of watch the
games we saw you on the sideline
week after week do you kind of put
yourself in on different plays or is it
more just absorbing what the different
guys in the corner doing
um i'll do it from both perspectives um
i do it from a sense of um you know
giving my voice
to what was going on on the floor for my
teammates okay this is what i saw
whatever
this is what i think we can exploit um
this is the mistakes we made
and then on the other side i put myself
in a position to say okay this is the
play i would have made um if i was in
that position i would have made that
play
um how i could affect the game in that
way um you know so
that's that's the stressful side when
you you know that if you're on the floor
you can make those plays and you can
help your teammates win
but you know you physically can't be out
there to do it so that's a stressful
point so
um it's both sides of the coin um you
know giving my teammates
you know pointers and things i see on
the floor but also having that stressful
point where you know you can't you know
affect the game because you can't play